.
What I would like to do in this presentation is to try to understand how
The protein component has to interact with each other in association with
ATP even produce mechanical movement
The reason I want to do this - First, it happens
Extra muscle cells, however
It will be the first presentation on how muscles work
Then we will talk about nerve stimulation
Muscles until you do their job
That's all I'll do in this show
What I did here is that I copied and pasted two pictures
For the protein from Wikipedia
This is myosin
It's already myosin 2 because it contains
Myosin protein
They are tangled around each other and you can see that
A complex view of protein or enzyme, however you wish
To say
I will tell you what the enzyme is called - because it is
Helps in the interaction of ATP with ADP and phosphate groups
This is why ATPase is called
It is a subcategory of ATPase enzymes
The one here is actin
What we will see in this presentation is how the Mosin
ATP is used to extend
You can also see it as a laxative and this is what
Creates mechanical energy
Let us draw it then
I will draw him on these two acts here
Let's assume that we have one of these meosin heads
When I tell the head of the mosquito, this one of the
The heads of the moss are here and then linked, or intertwined
And loves you around some of it
This one else wraps around
Now let's say we are dealing with one
From the heads of myosin
Let's just say it's on this site
Let me check the quality of my drawing
Let's assume that if you start from a site it looks like this
Then this is the tail which is linked
In another building we will talk about this
More specifically, but now this is the head of myosin and this
The starting site, does nothing
Now, ATP can extend and bind to this Miocene head, this
Enzyme, this protein, this enzyme is ATPase
Let me paint some of the ATP
If ATP extends and is associated with this here
Let's say that - and will not be
The bond is strong with this protein, but this is so
Gives you the decency
And soon ATP will link to the appropriate location of this
The enzyme or protein, the enzyme, is separated from actin
Let me write this down
If first, ATP binds to the head of myosin as soon as
This occurs, causing the myosin release of actin
This is the first step
I started with this one that touches Actin
The ATP comes and then is released
If in the next step - after that step, it will appear
So - and I want to draw it
In the same place
After that step, it will seem
So
Will be liberated
If it looks like this now we have ATP
Associated with it
I know that this is a bit complicated when it continues
Writing on the same thing, but we have
ATP is associated with it
Now the next step - ATP hydrolysis, phosphate
It will be uprooted
This enzyme is ATPase
That's what he does
Let me write this down
.
And what he does, he frees energy to lift
This myosin protein has a high degree of energy
Let me take the second step
This - it decomposes
It frees energy
We know that ATP is a spread of energy
Biological systems. If it frees energy
I paint it with a spark or an explosion, but
You can imagine it changing the assertion -
It beats this protein here until it moves
To a position where it is able to crawl along the meosin
If in the second step - + energy, energy then this - can
To say that it raises protein or myosin
To higher energy
You can imagine it pulsing with a pulsating load
For higher energy
And the emphasis on protein to be shaped
If the second step - what happens is that the phosphate group -
They are still linked, but separate from
Rest of the ATP
If ADP and that energy change
The installation if this protein now moves to
The site looks like this
Here we finish the second step
Let me make sure it is correct
At the end of the second step, it will appear
So
At the end of the second step, the protein will look
It's in its highest position
He has some energy now
And ends on this site
We still have the ADP
We still have - this is the adenosine and let's assume
We have two phosphate groups on ADP and
We still have one phosphate group there
Now, when the phosphate group is released - let me write
This is the third step
And remember, when we started, we were here
In the first step the ATP binds - in fact, it does
Connects, at the end of the first step, this causes in
Edit myosin protein
Then after the first step, we will take the second step
ATP will be converted into ADP phosphate
It frees energy and allows for myocene
It rises to this degree of high energy as a kind of
Link, you can think of, to the next degree
Of the Actin line
Now we smoke in a high degree of energy
The third step
In the third step, phosphate is released
.
Phosphate is released from myosin in step 3
That is the third step
As the phosphate group is released
And what you do, is to free energy from
The upper grade causes the payment of myosin protein
On the actin
This is called the energy strike, if you imagine it as a motor
This is what causes mechanical movement
So when the phosphate group is already released - remember
The original liberation is when you take
ATP to ADP in phosphate
And put it in this site of spring
When the phosphate releases it, this frees the spring
This frees the spring
What he is doing is pushing the string of actin
He drives the string of actin
You can consider this as a blow energy
We are creating mechanical energy
Click on any one you want to see attached - if
Actin is considered to be impregnated, and it does not matter what actin binds
It will move to the left
If you imagine that the myosin is clogged, the actin and
Anything associated with it will move to the right
in both cases
But here
We get muscle performance
Then step four - we have the ADP editor
ADP Editor
Then where were we before we took the step
First, add one extra degree to the left
Actin molecule
For me, this is very amazing
We already see how ATP energy can be used - we
We move from chemical energy energy bond in ATP to
Mechanical energy
With me, this is amazing because when I first learned about
ATP - People say, ATP was used to do anything in cells
The muscles are shrinking
Well, how do you move from a power connector to
Stuff shrinking, so you do what you see in
Our daily life which is mechanical energy?
This is what happens here
This is the fundamental issue here
You have to say, well, how this changes
Shape and all these things?
You should remember, that these proteins, depending on the
What is associated with it and what is linked
In them, they change shape
Some of these forms acquire more energy, and
If you do the right things, you will be able to power
Release and push another protein
But I find this missed
And now through the interaction of acetin and meosin
You can understand how muscles work